final days of summer are upon us and
Labor Day weekend is around the corner
but it's not too late to plant some last
minute travel according to travel expert
Janine tournamentor welcome back nice to
be here great to see you again are you
seeing a lot of people scrambling trying
to make travel plans right now
yeah I think amid this summer of lots of
issues at the airport and high prices
people are still looking to get away
because they maybe didn't take that trip
earlier in the summer and you know
looking ahead to Labor Day weekend if
that last long weekend of Summer and I
did find some deals out there that I
think people will be happy to see oh uh
more than happy to see including myself
so let's get to it where are you taking
us well look the first place I would
take you is closer to home we're talking
about Lake Tahoe I love this destination
in late summer because it's just a
beautiful time to get still hit the
trails get out on the water and you're
going to see that uh you know you could
actually drive there it's about a seven
hour drive so a little bit on the longer
side but great properties there this is
the kind of place where I don't mind
splurging a little bit places like the
Ritz Carlton Lake Tahoe which is
absolutely stunning but Lake Tahoe is
really nice in this late summer with all
the wildflowers blooming before the snow
starts to come in just a month or two oh
well speaking of the seasons next you
have New York what's going on there well
New York again a great time to visit you
know I love New York in August and
especially late August and Labor Day
weekend because a lot of the locals head
to the shore so you have a lot of City
to yourself that means you're going to
find Great Deals they found airfare from
Vegas to New York over Labor Day weekend
from 200 so really affordable compared
to what we've seen this summer lots of
availability great classic hotels but is
like the Algonquin which is part of the
Autograph Collection right in the Heart
of the City wow 200 to go to New York
yes I am in and next we have Portland
and then San Francisco
yeah so Portland another favorite easy
to get to on the west coast I do like
these short flights as well because you
can get there quick and not have to
worry about a lot of the issues you do
going across the country Portland again
just a beautiful place to visit in late
summer I love it because they have their
food trucks their beautiful Japanese
garden they get outside the city there's
so much beautiful hiking in the
mountains right nearby found airfare
over Labor Day weekend from Vegas from
160 dollars so even better to get to
Portland beautiful and I think I'm
seeing a picture of the Bay Area now San
Francisco right well I had to include
this one because you're not going to
believe what airfare I found over this
holiday weekend from 47 dollars round
trip from Vegas to San Francisco over
Labor Day weekend leaving on Friday
coming back on Tuesday you cannot really
do any better than that and look there's
that's where you save on the airfare and
then you stay in some great properties
places like the W San Francisco right in
the Heart of the City I love San
Francisco though because you have
everything right in the Bay Area but you
also have places like Muir Woods and
Sonoma right outside me we're getting
into harvest season with these Wine
Country areas and just one of the best
times of year to visit Janine thank you
so much I've lived in the bay so I know
very well it's got something for
everybody thank you for those tips we
needed them
my pleasure all right we'll send it over
to